هذا جنوب غزه الذي طالبت اسرائيل سكان
الشمال بالتوجه اليه لتفادي
القصف يلاحق القصف الجميع هنا لا يترك لهم
وقتا لالتقاط الانفاس مش عارف يعني الناس
وين تروح انا مافيش مكان يقول المرصد
الاورو متوسطي لحقوق الانسان ان اسرائيل
اطلقت على غزه ما يوازي ربع قنبله ال
نوويه هي قوه تدميريه هائله يواجهها سكان
غزه بعزيمه ولدت من رحم
المعاناه سياره اسعاف تتعرض للقصف
الاسرائيلي بمن فيها من مصابين ومسعفين
يقصف هؤلاء المصابون مرتين وكان ضرر القصف
الاول لا
يك وهذه سياره اسعاف اخرى تتعرض للقصف هي
مهمه محفوفه بالمخاطر وايصال المصابين الى
المستشفيات
ليس امرا
مضمونا ما زالت المستشفيات تستقبل
المصابين لكن ذلك قد يتوقف قريبا يقول
مدير مجمع الشفاء الطبي ان الوقود في
المجمع لا يكفي الا لساعات وتقول منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان
3500 مريض يواجهون خطر الموت في 35 مستشفى
اذا لم تحصل المستشفيات على الامدادات
اللازمه المنسق الاممي لعمليه السلام في
الشرق الاوسط يقول اننا نشاهد كارثه
انسانيه تصنع امام اعيننا لكن البعض لا
يريد ان يشاهد هذه
[موسيقى]
الكارثه انها لحظه حزينه ومظلمه في تاريخ
المنظمات الانسانيه والانسانيه ال جمعاء
ويبدو ان العالم ادار ظهره
لغزه تمتد الايادي من اجل كيس رغيف هؤلاء
وقفوا ساعات للحصول على رغيف سينفد دقيقه
قريبا ايضا يبدو ان القصف لا يكفي والحصار
الكامل هو الحل بالنسبه لاسرائيل انا عندي
في البيت سبع عائلات مشرده من الساعه 7
واقفه وهيها
ئ تقول منظمه الصحه العالميه ان المياه
ستنفذ قريبا في غزه وان مليونين فلسطيني
في غزه لا يحصلون على المياه حسب منظمه
الصحه العالميه بدا السكان يشربون مياها
ملوثه ما يهدد بكارثه
صحيه تتكدس الشاحنات على الجانب الاخر من
الحدود مع مصر لكن اسرائيل لا تسمح لها
بالعبور ويستمر القتل في غزه تقول اسرائيل
انها تستهدف المواقع العسكريه لحركه حماس
لكن النتيجه بعد كل قصف هي اختفاء احياء
سكنيه
باكملها تقول انها تستهدف مقاتل
حماس لكن اكثر من الف طفل الذين استشهدوا
حتى الان لا يمكن ان يكونوا
مقاتلين وكل يوم يطول سجل الشهداء في حرب
لا يريد العالم ان يرى
قبحها